Joe Biden says that he would not legalize
cannabis because it is a supposedly gateway
drug.
So this is a very good opportunity to dispel
what is a very tired and misunderstood talking
point.
And it's another confirmation, not that we
needed one, that Joe Biden's not progressive
period.
Joe Biden's still has some of the tired, centrist
ideas of many decades past.
So let's take a look at the video from Joe
Biden's rally in Las Vegas, Nevada over the
weekend.
And then, I mean, there's just so much to
say about this.
Uh, my name is Ricky.
Um, I have two questions show.
Um, my first question is, has your stance
on recreational marijuana changed?
And my second question is, do you mind signing
a poster for me in the moment?
I'd be happy to sign the poster and no, it
hasn't changed.
I think, look, I think States should be able
to make a judgment to legalize marijuana.
I agree with.
I think that's okay, but let me tell you the
truth of the matter is we, there's not nearly
been enough evidence that has been, uh, acquired
as to whether or not it is a gateway drug.
It's a debate and I want a lot more before
I legalize it nationally, I want to make sure
we know a lot more about the science behind
it.
It is really important to break this down
into pieces and go through it as I like to
do step-by-step because there's a lot of wrong
information here, but we also don't want to
go further than the science tells us.
We just want to be clear about what does the
science say and how do these things work.
The concept of a gateway drug, the concept
described by the idea of a gateway drug is
a real thing.
Okay.
The idea is you have a drug, it's either in
of itself, not addictive or less addictive,
but it leads to the use of more addicting
or deliberate debilitating drugs that one
may not as readily get into directly were
it not through the gateway or the door that
is opened by some other substance or drug.
So I'll give you an example.
Prescription opiate painkillers have been
proven to function as a potentially dangerous
gateway to street heroin.
That's true.
That's a huge problem.
You get a prescription, uh, for, uh, after
some medical procedure or an accident from
a doctor.
Um, you become addicted.
You start buying the same pills on the street,
you realize heroin is cheaper.
So you switched to the heroin, the prescription
opiates for so many people, uh, devastatingly
have been a gateway to street heroin.
That's a real problem.
Cannabis has not been shown to be a gateway
drug and there's actually a ton of science
about it.
You can go to Google scholar and you can read
lots of studies about it.
And the general findings after I reviewed
it, several dozen studies about this are that
there actually is a correlation between very
heavy cannabis use and the use of harder drugs,
but the problem is that that's deceptive and
that's as far as many people go.
There are many people who will say, well look,
studies have shown that really heavy cannabis
users are more likely to also be users or
abusers of heavier drugs.
There must be some causal relationship.
This is a very different issue altogether
and we shouldn't conflate what's going on.
A heavy cannabis user could be more likely
to get into harder drugs regardless of their
cannabis use and regardless of the legality
of cannabis.
What I mean by that is if you are the type
of person who either for biological reasons
or circumstantial family environmental reasons
are more likely to end up using heroin or
cocaine and crystal meth or whatever, you
are also more likely to do that regardless
of whether cannabis is legal.
I hope I'm being clear in what I'm saying
here.
Now there is one way in which marijuana or
cannabis can be a gateway drug and it's actually
something that suggests we should be legalizing
it.
Being around drug related violence, being
around drug related guns and criminality and
drug dealing that is happening in an illicit
way is going to put you in situations where
there are likely going to be users of heavier
drugs around you.
You could get sucked into it or into violence
or criminality simply by being around the
scene.
But that's actually an argument for the legalization
of cannabis to get people who choose to use
it away from situations and circumstances
where there are heavier drugs or there are
guns or there is violence.
That is the way in which cannabis being illegal
can serve as a gateway, not just to using
hard drugs, but also to getting people into
situations of criminality and violence that
are generated by cannabis being illegal.
So back to Joe Biden, it's no surprise that
this is what he's saying.
He's being upfront and I disagree with his
position.
So the one thing I, I'm not a Biden guy, but
this is yet more evidence that Biden's not
progressive.
The one thing, I appreciate that Joe Biden
is doing this election cycle, and I've said
this before and some people get mad for, for
me pointing this out, but it's true.
Joe Biden doesn't seem to be pretending to
be a progressive.
In other words, he makes very clear on the
stage.
He's not into this Medicare for all thing
that other people are talking about.
He makes it very clear when he's asked.
I think cannabis is a gateway drug and I wouldn't
legalize it.
I disagree vehemently or as I like to save
a humanly, even though I, I don't even know
where I heard it.
I just find it funny.
I disagree vehemently with Joe Biden on these
positions, but he's not playing coy the way
some other candidates have been doing.
And it makes it really clear that Biden's
not the guy for me, I don't have to dig too
deep to figure that out.
So, um, he's not the person I want as the
progressive, uh, as the democratic nominee,
rather.
He's not the person I want as president, but
he's being upfront with us.
He's completely wrong, but he is being upfront
with us here.